white house that feels like a fortress
with a resident unwilling to concede
despite growing impatience from his
opponents
the long arduous slog of counting
continues and it seems to be favoring
joe biden
[Applause]
but mr trump's fans believe he's
stealing the election
america divided around its own democracy
democrats have already started to adopt
the language of victory
president-elect biden has a strong
mandate to lead
and will have a strong democratic house
with him
and many democrats in the senate this
has been a life or death fight for the
fate of our democracy as he says the
soul of our country
we did not win every battle in the house
but we did win the war
they face a commander-in-chief unwilling
to leave the bunker though
or accept the process if you
count the legal votes i easily win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us
[Music]
it was the sound of a forlorn and
furious
firebrand followed today by this
statement
we believe the american people the
president said deserve to have
full transparency into all vote counting
and election certification
and that this is no longer about any
single election
this is about the integrity of our
entire election process
it's not a man with one foot out the
door and his loyalists aren't ready for
a quick departure either
i'm going to stand with president trump
if a democrat were doing this it'd be
cheered on
we're not going to let the media
intimidate us into
exploring whether or not this these
contests were fairly had
but there are some senior republicans
deeply unsettled by the president's
claims of fraud
presented so far with no evidence
in a statement senator mitt romney said
he is wrong to say that the election was
rigged
corrupt and stolen doing so damages the
cause of freedom here and around the
world
weakens the institutions that lie at the
foundation of the republic
and recklessly inflames destructive and
dangerous passions
there is a structure in place for the
transfer of power and an inauguration
stage already being built
but right now there is no official
winner no guarantee this will be done by
christmas
a year that may fittingly end with a
tumultuous timeline
cordelia lynch sky news washington